let's talk about this bruin case man i'm
really excited for this one we got the
story from the daily news it'll make you
laugh
nyc mayor adams alarmed over pending
supreme court ruling that could ease
concealed weapons rules quote it keeps
me up at night oh poor baby a pending
u.s supreme court decision that would
allow more concealed weapons to be
carried on new york city streets has
been keeping mayor adams up at night
all of us should be extremely alarmed
about what the supreme court can do
when he says all of us is referring to
establishment authoritarians because yes
right not the people correct that's not
what he means yes yes because he's
worried about the wild wild west he says
right here's the problem i live in new
york city it is the wild wild west now
this future dystopian thing you think of
is today
right so yes is that hilarious like
democrats always warn you about the
possibility of what they've already done
yes it's already there will be crime
everywhere it's like yes no we know that
that's a possibility because it's
happening in the places where you
control yes check this out they say
under the state central law new yorkers
must show a specific need for why they
should be able to carry a concealed
firearm before they're permitted to do
so however in most states they just
reject your reason they go well you need
a reason that's not a good reason yes
which is ridiculous that law was
challenged by the new york state rifle
and pistol association bravo good
certain and ladies which claimed it
violated 2a under the constitution
supreme court justices have suggested
that they agree that the law infringes
on gun owner rights and is expected to
rule on the case during the current term
the decision would also impact
california hawaii maryland new jersey
and massachusetts oh you love to hear it
yes it keeps me up at night we have some
of the most stringent gun permitting
laws i'm extremely concerned about this
my legal team is talking to other cities
to determine how we can come together to
prepare for this ruling here's what i'd
love
all right in dcv heller supreme court
basically said the right to keep and
bear arms extends to all states not just
from the federal government the idea
before was that the federal government
could not infringe upon your rights to
keep and bear arms but state's good dc
versus heller was like nah everyone can
have guns
and well i'm sorry that wasn't the case
that that was the case as it permitted
uh pertain to the federal government in
dc versus heller they were like the
federal government can't stop you from
having a handgun
it was mcdonald v chicago
where two years later they said
yes this includes all of the states as
well because it was the dc jurisdiction
now it was state now it was all the
state so it was nationwide you could
keep and bear arms all of a sudden we
see a wave across the country of shall
issue states meaning you apply for a
concern okay you gotta get
here's what i'm hoping for
i am hoping for the one in a billion uh
chance ruling that the supreme court
says in fact any requirement of a permit
is an infringement upon your right to
keep and bear arms because let's be
honest it is
if you have to get permission from the
government and they can say no
your rights are being infringed
if it was to not infringe upon your
rights the government has no say
whatsoever i can keep and bear arms you
can't stop me what about a corporation i
know you are a 2a purist i know you are
yeah i'm actually not a 2a purist well
you're actually not a purist and you
need a loss sir we're going to
and here is my here's my and here is my
exception i think you could have a
regulation it is possible in theory not
in practice is how it works but in
theory you could have a regulation on
firearms that does not infringe how so
an example might be if you are going to
let's say this happens and a bunch of
people decide to buy firearms and we
find that smaller statute people don't
understand the power of uh you know
certain firearms and the backlash is is
hurting them and the state would say hey
if you're going to sell a firearm you
have to put a rating system on it that
would say big small little whatever
that's a that's a that's a regulation
but doesn't stop me from buying i can
buy what i want but if i choose to sell
it i've got to let someone know this is
rated one two or three when it comes to
recoil so i think that type of
regulation doesn't infringe but may be
good for the population as a whole to
understand well so so so in in what way
do you see that actually uh something
like that being implemented
i'm saying i'm saying you said pure
purist i'm just pushing back on the
purest now i'm not saying i disagree
with like a rating system yeah i think
when it comes to things like commerce if
you were to say you you have to make
sure that you know you you maybe you
give your caliber in both you know
imperial and metric or something like
making these up obviously but if you
were to create a regulation like that
that doesn't infringe it simply let's
sumer know what they're purchasing i
think it does infringe
i know your peers why i was teasing you
you're putting that's exactly why yes so
the challenge is
i think
the government using circuitous methods
to try and restrict things is a common
tactic and we shouldn't tolerate it but
again remember i said in theory not in
practice sure sure because in practice
the government will always do that you
know what they did with the stamp text
for marijuana yep they they said you
want to buy marijuana you got to buy a
stamp yeah then they stopped issuing
stamps yes yeah you know homie don't
play that so when you've got gun stores
and they're like we want to sell guns
then all of a sudden the government says
it's not an infringement upon the
individual's right to bear arms it's a
regulation for businesses what happens
when these businesses then go okay we'll
do the rating system who certifies the
rating system they go dhs okay how do we
get that done well dhs is shut down for
the next year
sorry you can't sell guns anymore so
it's an infringement infringement is
defined as an as an act so as to limit
or undermine something if in any way
there is a law passed requiring you to
do a thing they are limiting your
ability and if it's the commerce of that
is a private citizen's right to keep and
bear arms and transacted as so let me
push back then
it does say well regulated now when they
said regulated what they meant was
to make regular but right to do things
like to say what is regular but that has
nothing to do with the the with the uh
um
with the direction of the second
amendment the right of the people to
keep and bear arms yes but to
descriptive statements to make regular
would mean to say things like um
to understand what caliber is right to
make a contract rule that i know when
i'm purchasing ammunition what is a
dozen but that has nothing to do with
the with second amendment
says regulate right in the second
amendment and and why does it say that
to make it regular it would be like me
saying um libraries being important for
someone to read yeah people have a right
to access books
sure that doesn't mean the books can be
regulated or anything it's me making a
point about but what if it's said in a
well-regulated library
what if it's what if it's like it
doesn't say that but what it of all
regular militia being necessary to the
security of a free state yeah so what if
it said in people need to have well
regular libraries let's say it said that
the people need to be able to have books
but the second amendment does not
require anything to be regulated
i didn't say requires so what's the
what's the point of i'm i'm saying that
you could have a rule
a a a a you could have a law in theory
again i'm i'm purposely saying theory in
theory you could have a way of making
the practice of selling a firearm
regular that would not infringe on
someone purchasing it but regular has
nothing to do with what is prescribed in
the second amendment
it is describing their opinion on why
people should have guns and then it says
separately the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be in front
it also says a well-regulated militia
should not be infringed i think that
they're saying it doesn't say that a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed it sounds
like they're specifically saying that
the a well-regulated your right to
establishing a well-regulated militia
shall not be infringed
it's not saying that i mean the rest of
you
the original second amendment actually
went on to argue that
military or militia involvement has no
bearing on whether or not you can keep
or bear an arm that was actually
included in the original draft they
removed it because they were scared that
it would argue conscription isn't
allowed that people could reject
conscription so so let me then move to
the next important piece which you have
states like california and new york and
again i'm a new yorker so i get this
about ev every poll you take in new york
state about 60 give or take of new
yorkers actually want more gun control
too bad i'm saying they want it yeah so
with that in mind politicians are going
to act accordingly right they're going
to
regardless of constitution they're going
to act accordingly so they're going to
try their damnedess to stop everything
they possibly can so how do you move
forward in a state
like california new york that is going
to go out of its way to somebody go no
just no federal intervention and we do
it already like if you go to new york
city right now with it with a firearm
that you own it is on it is locked and
unloaded it is following every single
tsa guideline to the letter you will go
to rikers island that's right they will
take you and put you to rikers island
they wait for people to land knowing
that they have guns in the checked
baggage yep and they wait as soon as you
put a finger on the bag yup they come
and arrest you correct
that is new york city that is exactly
correct new jersey maryland very similar
yes so how do you because these cops are
scumbags so i know what you want and i
get what you want i'm actually not
against what you're saying
i'm trying to say but i have a realistic
issue here in my state where most of my
people in my state think that more
regulation is a good idea i don't care
what they think and you don't have to
you're not a politician right if you're
a politician you've got to care because
they're going to vote for you they're
going to put you in charge and they're
and they're the ones who's going to put
the da's in charge so the da's going to
decide who they're going to prosecute
who they're not right the da's in new
york city do this job because the people
in the city want them to that's why
they're doing it they're voting for
these das to do this and so people want
this so
we would need federal intervention in
into new york to stop the infringement
upon people's rights and i view it as no
no different than if let's say new york
decided they were going to segregate
schools and the national guard or army
had to be called in to dec to uh uh to
desegregate that's probably good idea
actually in new york because they do
segregate schools but anyway so that's
besides the point my view of things is
that um the constitution is it's the
founding document the the supreme law of
this land you got a problem with it you
can amend it you need popular support to
do so and you're not going to get it you
can try and i i say that realistically
by all means i encourage everyone to try
to petition all of the states to have a
convention of states to make the changes
that they hope will happen there's a
reason why gun access is expanding it's
because most people actually want access
to guns when they say most people want
gun control it's because advocacy groups
are lying to you and i mean that
absolutely they say things like do you
think there should be background checks
for gun purchases and most people say
for sure yeah because there are then
they say people want universal
background checks then they say what
we're talking about is private sales you
didn't ask that of the person when you
took the poll right you look at you you
look at uh liberal gun owners of which
there are many yep you look at democrats
and it's like 50 somewhat percent
own weapons you look at states like
vermont places like where bernie sanders
comes from and this shows you the
duplicitousness of these politicians
that bernie sanders comes from a state
that has actually one of the lowest ages
for owning a gun that has some of the
highest gun ownership where he
campaigned in 2015 saying
weapons is a urban versus rule issue yep
today he says these gun control laws
don't go far enough because he is just a
lion it's like you described yes they
just want to get elected yes and they
won't just stand up and say this is what
is and why it is and if you want to
change it we can work to change it but
this is the way things are just because
60 of people in new york want to strip
the rights away from the american people
does not mean they get to yeah sadly and
this is the piece i'll bring up again
and people get mad when i say this the
only party that is even trying to do
what you're talking about the
libertarian party that's right the only
one republicans are are caving democrats
in this one i'll give them chris the the
the i'll give them credit recorders do
at least they're open about grabbing the
guns at least they're opening they're
saying we hate guns that's one thing
they're saying no the republicans say
they love guns and then still support
grabbing a gun it's true but you know
among democrats they go no one is trying
to ban your guns although they say take
your gun yes right they are trying to
ban the guns they're not trying to take
them what they do is they make you they
make you a criminal retroactively it's
how democrats and they're very good they
did my state atf did it with yes with
the 80 lowers 100 they're doing it with
ghost guns they're into 3d printed guns
yep so i was i was talking to one of
these um
uninitiated people who don't know
anything about guns but for some reason
want to regulate them they have they
have no idea what they're talking about
and they made it they posted a meme
where it said no one is trying to ban
your guns and then i said here's a list
of my guns that are banned in maryland
so uh why the one i love to bring up is
the m1a which is a banned assault weapon
in maryland but the scar 20s is totally
fine even though they're a similar
caliber and one's more modern and
arguably better
how does that make sense how does it
make sense that you can load up a ksg25
with 41 mini slugs but you can't have a
six-shot semi-automatic benelli because
the laws make no sense correct it's not
about
it
it's you know what you've described it
perfectly
angry people who who don't know what
they're talking about politicians who
say yeah yeah throw them whatever they
want and the system crumbles around us
because corrupt politicians offer stupid
people non-solutions that just go up the
system thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you